magnificent marvelous legendary
undulating as gracefully through the
vast sky above as the watery depths
below the chinese dragon is one of the
world's most globally recognized
monsters their behavior could be
described as benevolent but their
appearance can still inspire fear and
awe
these dragons or long as they're called
in chinese mythology have been a crucial
component of religion culture mythology
and folklore in china for thousands of
years the dragon is one of the four
benevolent animals in chinese mythology
and one of the 12 members of the chinese
zodiac and those are only small parts of
their influence
dragons played a major role in china's
history they were both creators and
destroyers and controlled the elements
so what was it about the chinese dragon
that made it such a central figure in
chinese culture
i'm dr emily zarka and this
is monstrum
the dragon was born in china a long time
ago and has appeared throughout ancient
and modern history a jade dragon
discovered from hong kong culture dates
to around 6 000 years ago and dragon
heads appear on oracle bones from 1300
bce
more recently disney chongqi gave us a
beautiful and mythologically accurate
representation of the creature that's a
pretty solid track record
wong fu a chinese historian and
philosopher in the eastern han dynasty
wrote that the dragon's unique
appearance is actually a composite of
many different animal features and the
list is long
their heads are the same shape as a
camel their ears are like a bull and
they regard us with eyes similar to a
hair or a murderous demon depending on
the source
atop their majestic heads grow the
antlers of a stag they have the writhing
body of a snake and the well-armored
belly of a clam they have the feet of a
tiger in the enormous towns of an eagle
finally covering their whole body are
the protective scales of a carp
some scholars believe that these various
attributes evolved out of the influence
of the disparate tribes that eventually
unified into the china we know today
others see them as emblematic of
desirable human characteristics or as a
representative amalgamation of ancient
spiritual totems
some traditions claim that the chinese
dragons conceal a large pearl in their
throat or chin the pearl often depicted
in art as a glowing white disk in a
dragon's claw or mouth may represent the
sun the moon or the earth or maybe it's
just a giant jewel regardless the
dragon's ability to hold the precious
orb represents immense power
even the number of scales on the chinese
dragon's body carries important
significance the number is said to be
117 which in traditional chinese
philosophy and religion represents a
perfect balance of yin negative essence
and yang positive acids
because of this natural duality while
usually compassionate the dragon can be
malicious as well or even just really
invested in politics
in the 17th century scholar said zhao
jo's text the five assorted offerings
tells the story of his own encounter
with dragons according to set while
traveling by sea at 10 years old with
his uncle on a diplomatic mission they
were suddenly plagued by wind rain hail
thunder and lightning three dragons
surrounded them
at first everyone was terrified of the
extraordinary creatures but an elder
remarked that they must be there to hear
the emperor's message
they interact with gods and immortals in
the heavens even without wings they can
fly through the air they are
shapeshifters capable of taking on any
size or shape including human form
they can turn invisible at will are
highly intelligent and in some stories
they can even speak
the deep meanings attributed to chinese
dragons are ancient so much so that
their exact origins are largely lost to
the past the evidence that we do have
however suggests dragons were a
universal facet in all early cultures in
china even though traditions and
spiritual significance differed in the
guideways through mountains and seas an
encyclopedic tome and chinese bestiary
penned between the 4th and 1st century
bce the dragon appeared as a nature
deity known as the god of thunder who
uses his own belly to drum up echoing
booms there were even so-called dragon
cults religious groups that worshiped
dragons and gave offerings to appease
them as aquatic semi-divine beings
dragons control rainstorms hail wind
tornadoes floods and all bodies of water
dragons helped explain the rain cycle
during the song dynasties and were thus
also said to bring thunder and lightning
this was an important development
because if humans could summon dragons
then they had a semblance of control
over rain as well during this same
period paintings of dragons dramatically
increased in ancient chinese cosmology
there are four kinds of dragons the
celestial dragon dragon of hidden
treasure the underground or underworld
dragon and spiritual dragon who control
rain and winds but in other traditions
the taxonomy expands to nine an
auspicious number in chinese numerology
and interestingly the same number of
animals the dragon borrows its features
from
joining the classification system are
the winged dragon the horn dragon the
coiling dragon the yellow dragon and the
dragon king the dragon king concept was
only introduced after the arrival of
buddhism in china when buddhism came to
the area dragons were adopted as a
symbol of enlightenment as well as
royalty buddhism was then imported from
china to japan around the 7th century
and dragons came along with it dragons
were later incorporated into shintoism
as well the shinto god susanu was
believed to have killed an eight-headed
dragon which certainly seems like a
monster slayer story to me
in chinese mythology when one of the
four poles that held up the sky
collapsed one of the disastrous
consequences was great flooding brought
on by the black dragon a malevolent
creature who could only be stopped by
the mother goddess nua but other dragons
are not so monstrous after all one of
those world-building pillars was
constructed by the green dragon one of
the deities of creation
and yet another creation story from the
bi peoples when the world was created a
great golden dragon lay in slumber under
the sea
when one of two warring suns dropped
into the ocean the sea began to boil
awoken and enraged by this the golden
dragon swallowed the sun it began to
burn him eventually bursting from his
chest and becoming clouds trees flowers
grass and animals of all kinds
so to sum it up not all chinese dragons
are the same they serve different
purposes
some are celestial others belong to the
river some protect treasure act as
deities or serve as a connection to the
spiritual oh and they can have human
offspring or more specifically emperors
this is one reason why chinese dragons
are intimately linked to imperial
history during the han dynasty to qin
dynasty period the great and powerful
dragon became associated with emperors
as a way to show the rulers had been
divinely chosen the first han emperor
known as the yellow emperor was said to
be the offspring of a human mother and a
divine dragon
this supposed heritage trickled down to
all elements of the emperor's authority
from their robes to their beds
yellow or golden dragons were
particularly revered by imperial powers
and the five clawed dragon became an
official imperial symbol in the 14th
century
their claws represent the emperor's
power over the five elements wood fire
earth metal and water
eventually everyone else was banned from
wearing any clothing that pictured a
five-clawed dragon
that's not to say that all stories of
dragons were based on mythology animism
or legend
ancient animals likely played a role as
well
yep we're talking dragons and fossils as
early as china's jin dynasty which
lasted from 265 to 317 ce we find a text
mentioning the discovery of what were
believed to be dragon bones in what's
now sichuan province
a lot of the sediment in this area dates
back to the middle in late jurassic
period and the area is full of fossils
remains of dinosaurs like the predatory
theropods were found there as well as a
massive sauropod with an extremely long
neck that could grow up to 25 meters
long dragons inhabit exotic spaces
mysterious watery depths expansive skies
and heavenly realms their powers are
frightening but inspirational and
they're beautiful in their strength and
otherworldliness
luck power wisdom bravery strength
chinese dragons inspired everything from
religious practices to the national
emblem countless astounding artworks and
architectural marvels to the globally
famous dragon dance the creature is
inseparable from the history of the
chinese people to embrace the chinese
dragon is to celebrate chinese culture
thanks for watching let me tell you a
little bit about subcultured a brand new
documentary series from pbs that focuses
on lesser-known communities and folks
that have a major impact on the
mainstream what can somebody who is
completely blind teach you about video
games how did anime become a 25 billion
dollar industry check it out over on pbs
voices and tell them dr z sent you
in chinese mythology when the four poles
that held up the sky collapsed
this dragon that made it such a slur
webweb